welcome to this video playing ceases
from Finland hmm come on let's let's go
let's play sloth nope the London system
always always nice the two to play
against yeah it's a notoriously boring
but certainly not a bad opening for
white
yeah this is one of the good lines for
black available if it takes on f5 I take
on b2 and grab the rook so Quincy one
must be played securing the bishop yeah
this is in fact interesting now um what
about Queen a five if I go queen 85 and
he takes on c4 Bishop e3 I wonder about
this this may be interesting come on
let's try that if it plays before I'm
some second apiece not before it takes
Bishop takes ok on Queen Queen d1 and
quaint you maybe it's got night b3
no I can take on c1 Knight a5 Bishop b2
is actually quite good not sure what he
is thinking always playing that wow I
can just take here and play Bishop b2
this should win should win material yeah
i can just recapture you have nowhere to
go with the rook I mean to d1 but I'm
winning the exchange after that Bishop
c2 we are just winning the exchange I'll
take here and he needs to play king e 2
unfortunately i don't have work v8 this
would be would be excellent right okay
let's let's win the exchange shouldn't
this shouldn't be too bad
the only thing is I have a slightly weak
structure on c6 so 95 at some point
might win the c6 pot it still felt
slightly tricky he's always controlling
be aid so that rook p8 is never possible
yeah I wonder you should probably take
time
taking everything with the check
kingi to Bishop t1 check and 92 there's
always 90 form oh I can take the one
simply taking everything off
okay just take it with a check right yes
check and yeah this is in fact
interesting but take with the porn and
SB should be five but just kinky 7am
don't really see a problem
okay and this now Bishop b5 can be M can
be a bit bit annoying but here well
again I go here and that's night f2 wow
this is this is this is important
there's 9f to if you give this check
check he needs to worry about night f2
so this is the only move I know I can
take and play will be eight you know
this is quite convincing yeah very
convincing actually just take here and
King e74 loopsy aid yeah no card to play
that's it I can easily enter with the
one of the roofs of both looks just take
bold files and make sure there's no
counter plane and at all
mmm yeah
yeah we'll just come on just just take
everything was briefly thinking if I can
play for a mate but just just take our
table pawns
probably a prima white resign yes it
didn't matter it was was just completely
winning yeah he I think he just he just
overlooked why you miscalculated
something in those in those early
complications he just needs to go Queen
D 1 I mean this I thought would be
interesting in fact the computer gives
gives a direct wind for black this is
interesting yeah Bishop see to it while
I saw this this idea but I thought while
he will he will have something against
this but it doesn't seem to be the case
then then he really shouldn't take on c4
nothing this is not a play will move
then interesting this I wanted to
sacrifice Oh Bishop before us actually
it would direct women oh very
interesting I played some interesting
stuff without really knowing the one
with the conduct when song I would have
played this actually quickly I thought
this would be would be already nice will
see three and Bishop see 394 I mean this
is certainly interesting Gant computer
gives blog an edge but this this infant
is even better with 92 cannot avoid that
black so outright winning and remarkable
so we cannot take on c4 simply and not
be four compounds to play a form we are
quite sensible because Bishop e3 was a
thread anyway and here i need to maybe
take it no loops no retreat which is I
don't know interesting but certainly not
terrible for white i mean i don't i
don't have any problems here but why
should should be still okay this is a
slight weakness but it's not clear that
i can benefit from that directly yeah
interesting thanks for watching